I'm Sebastian, that thing there is my last
name.
I live in California now, but, um, it's actually
really nice to be back in Europe where Umlauds
and accents are normal occur answers. Sorry
for my bad voice, I think I'm allergic for
bad API. I work for Facebook now, I'm not
an evangelist, I just code stuff, I'm just
some dude. I also represent Facebook on TC
39 on standards committee on ECMAScript. Don't
worry, the bad parts are not mine, they're
someone else's.
I guess a lot of people here have a favorite
library. There was your favorite library‑‑
nothing? React that's a good call. (Laughing)
do you guys use libraries for everything,
like the same library, like utility library,
like underscore in how many people use underscore?
Cool. JQuery? Something like Angular High
Level YUY? Oooo ... sorry, guys (Laughing)
well, this is the great part about JavaScript,
our community, if you look platforms like
EEO, Andriod or proprietary. Do whatever the
platform owner tells you that's right to do.
There's a stock secret black box you can't
touch, everyone tells you you can't do better
than they did, which is not true, let's be
honest, it's not true in the Java committee.
We have a vibrant community of framework,
we have discussion and fights about how many
package managers we need manage all of our
libraries, I think a lot of them are called
MPM actually. But do we really need this many
OA's, how many ways do we fled the accessDM
attributes. You know all the APIs in Ember
data, do you know how many ways to filter
an array just in underscore? Is it same as
well dash depending on which version you use
and what you opt in to. Do you even know tall
APIs in the standard JavaScript library? What
about VS 6? Job recruiters and job descriptions
are looking for experience with specific libraries,
and if you know the same concept under different
name, you're actually not good enough, because
like you're not going to get ramped up quick
enough before the company pivots, right. It's
starting to get a little bit annoying with
all this proliferation, but, of course, you
have a solution for this, you created your
own library and now there's only one thing
you is to learn. It's probably super easy,
solves all the educations and all the names
are super easy for you to understand. How
streamlined? JavaScript JS is really hard
to learn. Imagine this is like the first day
and you get dropped into code based complicated
weapon App, in the middle of the web App,
first day you have no idea how it works how
many calls in to JavaScript libraries do you
see that you've never seen before. Imagine
this is the life of thousands of your colleagues.
We had our own core libraries at Facebook
as well.
One of the most common questions we had was
so which Facebook specific module corresponds
to this underscore or JQue arey function?
It's not that the library is too big, the
library is pretty cool. It doesn't matter
if there's too many bytes, there's way to
optimize and filter those, it's actually total
amount of APIs that you have to learn to be
productive in this industry. That's really
difficult these days. And I don't think this
is inherent to a diverse ecosystem. I don't
think it's inherent to programming in general.
I think I found a process that can help us
minimize this problem. First of all, listen
to slow moving standard organizations. Then
write some spaghetti code. Never abstract
until it actually causes bugs. Once it does
cause a bug, subtract an abstraction and as
as much surface area as you destruct if it.
This doesn't sound like best practices, and
no one wants to listen to slow moving standards
story. Let me get back to that a little bit
later. First, some history. 2005. Late 2005.
It was an interesting era for the web, it
was before internet explorer 7, JavaScript
update for 6 years, ES 4 was being drafted,
it was going to go into failure. But minimal
JavaScript, the line of library we had, the
community had enough, we started to take things
into our own hands, and this was an era where
all the libraries started to see proliferation.
A lot of them were like prototype, based JS,
those two heavily inspired Moo tools, which
I kind of worked on a little bit. A lot of
those bad things were my fault. But, of course
libraries couldn't agree on a standard way
of extending prototypes and having global
name space so the best practice became like
J curry and underscore because they had their
owne own separate name space.
Then ES 5 came along and it became popular
to patch prototypes again, this time it's
called poly fills. A lot of those poly fills
naturally replaced prototype and Moo tools
because they were sharing the same name space.
But, the library in their own name space,
like underscore and J query lived on. They
actually had better APIs at the time because
there were better documented and it was easier
to learn because there was no standard that
you can rely on. And the rational that they
still live on it's empowering to have an abstraction
on top of the native feature, you with tweak
performance, fix thing Ms.The speck without
relying on a standards body to fix it for
you. Even TC 39 for JavaScript would even
argue if you're not quite happy with this,
you should just use your own ten mow library
and build something on top of the standards.
But which one do we use? There's at least
two ways to do it now, there's the standard
way, and the library way, and there's multiple
libraries, we asked ourselves because we got
this question a lot, should we adopt an API
like popular library or underscore or maybe
a little dash, but which one of them, and
which version and is this going to be maintained.
Do we even control the source? Is it community
driven, or is it controlled by one person?
Do we require this library from all of our
source, or do we decouple it with some other
dependency. So, let's take a minute to look
at why we actually use JavaScript to begin
with. It's not best language in the world,
whatever your favorite style is, there's at
least one Bert language out there that will
compile down to JavaScript. We can just use
that instead, right? Well, we use JavaScript
because it's ubiquitous, it's something that
people could agree on.
This is why general purpose programming languages
keep winning out against DSLs and custom languages.
And by introducing divergence in the library
community, we're actually undermining what
JavaScript is great. So back at Facebook we
started building source trance filers for
ES 6 features, we invested a lot in E 6, we
became very early adopters throughout our
entire code base, we joined TC 39 to start
working on ES 7. There are some problems with
this technique though, there's some native
functions that are shower than reimplementation
of this, load ash shows this over and over
again. It's easy to solve just monkey batch
it, just overwry native version with one that's
faster, this is a string of JavaScript that
you can actually do this. Sometimes, don't
tell anyone, but you can actually use Shams
as well that are not quite compatible just
to get the extra little performance boost,
just make sure you're continuously try knoll
the standards as it mosting along and also
try to not expose dependencies on non‑standard
behavior. There's a lot of compatibility problems
with just relying on poly fills. In the early
day was Spec changes a lot you basically have
to live with it as a library rather than a
final draft of a spec, you continuously upgrade,
you can really only have one version in one
realm at a time, we have a lot of solutions
to solve this, another problem is that you
mite have to load like a huge poly fill on
an initial page load instead of doing the
modular loading.
And all of this stuff is really difficult
to get right, but we, and a lot of our people
are trying to build Open Source tooling, to
support your environment, stacked actually
enable you do this. And this is all hard work,
but it allowstous have a very simple story,
at Facebook, we use JavaScripts standard library.
There's one way to do things, and it's the
standard way. And it's it avoids a very simple
problem. It avoids bike shedding, bike shedding
is the biggest waist of all. We leave that
to standard mailing list. It reminds me the
least intuitive lessons I learned from an
organization. The top‑down authority is
best used on the very least important decisions,
not the most important decisions. For example
I really recommend you force a strict and
comprehensive style guide just because it
avoids this discussion on every of pole request
or every DIsive which style you're going to
use and every person isn't going to have to
fight to get their style (DIV) you might be
asking yourself, JavaScript standard library
doesn't have all features of my library, so
what do I replace this with? Well, often the
answer is just write some more boilerplate
code. It'll take you a few seconds longer,
you don't take on dependency. The person coming
to fix your code does haven't to know about
your obscure function and to pointing out
their version with the same or different names
that someone else thought was better, and
better looking. This can be really annoying
to have all this repetitive code that looks
ugly when we all want beautiful code, right.
Except, this process fundamentally has no
end, ever. We're simply never going to realize
state of software anywhere van that where
everything is supremely satisfying. And that's
an emotional realization. This was an early
quote from early Facebooker, but to put it
another way, you're not going to find a perfect
library API, you have good looking code now
will look bad in a year, and you or someone
else will have to go upgrade it. You might
not remember what abstraction you found was
cool, today. However, it's not allGloomy.
You write your code a little differently,
Ellen new patterns that allow you to structure
your code a different way that achieve your
goal‑‑ now, learning these patterns
is quite difficult, and this is definitely
a learning curve, but that makes you a better
programmer in general. Large frameworks they
usually is an API for every kind of use case
you can just search for that API, like ask
for it on stack overflow and you can find
a link to it. When you learn patterns you
have to read a book or tutorial or find different
ways to express the same thing. It's a different
way to search for things, but, essentially
it's the aim problem. It's just a slightly
different solution. And, if you structure
a code in a way that uses patterns, instead
of black box libraries, it's mouchoirs for
the next person to read your code, to actually
understand what's going on. And this is the
most important lesson I've learned at Facebook.
It's much easier to recover from no abstraction
than the wrong abstraction.
So, this kind of says a spaghetti code can
be Bert than a structure code this is very
counterintuitive to modern programmers, at
least. It's that the structure abadd overhead
to what a new coder needs to learn just to
get up to speed with your code base. But,
you know, like one little abstraction can't
hurt, but abstractions tend to spread, because
toll is just a layer of abstractions, one
on top of the other, and everything you have
on top of your abstraction will node the be
unwound. You have to unwind every layer with
a total and complete understanding of the
intraquasis of that system to get back to
the original layer and then rebuild it if
there. And, that means that it can actually
be more‑‑ a lot easier to upgrade verbose,
repetitive and explicit code than it is to
upgrade an abstraction. Now I'm not saying
like bad code, spaghetti code is better. It's
really like Fettucci ine code.
Have you ever lived with like a large App
that was built on the wrong framework? And
you tried to upgrade it but you never could,
because you could never understand how the
underlying framework worked. Your had an existing
App that was just written in haste, it was
all spaghetti code, maybe it was good spaghetti
code, maybe it was Fettuccine code. A lot
of abstractions lots of repetition. Which
one left you with more of a usable code? Abstraction
comes with a significant cost and significant
risk, so it's better to abstract to begin
with and once you have a nice Feuccin e code
base start finding repeated patterns, if the
pattern doesn't lead to bugs, don't fix it.
It might look ugly but it's not hurting anyone.
Try to generalize it, and you only risk adding
bugs in the generalization. It only adds surface
area to hurt everyone. But once it starts
causing bugs then it becomes a problem because
it's repetition and some algorithms can be
difficult to get right and then it starts
causing bugs then you generalize, you create
an abstraction, but make sure the abstraction
can be used for wide variety of use cases
because it has to make it worth it's weight.
It might even be subject for standardtion
if it's general enough. And this is where
slow moving standards can actually help you.
If it convenience recall enough and useful
enough, it will be accepted as a standard,
maybe it will be accepted as a draft and you
can sort of continue from that.
But if it's not, then maybe it's not actually
worth the weight it's adding, maybe you need
to rethink or prove its value. Now let's talk
about the DOM. There are apparently 25 methods
to work with attributes alone, you can also
access attributes throw properties. That's
still no reason to use a J query, the browser
inconsistencies could be poly filled and the
rest is just basically adding some sugar.
It's not solving the actual structural problem
and the come Plaintiff's Exhibitty of the
actual DOM, the living DOM, and that thing
is the thank that leads to bugs. No and Already
and Ember tries to address this by change
tracking and adding‑‑ bites on top of
the DOM, you adopt have to access it directly
and solves the bugs. In theory web components
and similar efforts can actually work on standardizing
these patterns then there's one thing you
have to learn and this data mining, web components
world. Except, they don't actually remove
as much as they add. The surface area of the
framework, these paradigms, it's huge, there's
a lot of things you have to learn. Learning
how to use nit a fully structured way, and
the intraquasis of that is still huge. And
that continues to be the case even when it's
standardized. But, with this paradigm it's
all necessary. And that fende tends to happen
when you keep building straight on top of
existing ideas.
So, sometimes joust have to rethink the whole
stack. Come up with a smaller surface area.
So we thought, mutation is actualry the hard
part of the DOM‑‑ mutation is actually
hard part of the D onlyM so what we through
it away and do it like a patriot load. We
created react. We oar not trying to diverge
from standard, we think functional approach
taken by react means we can drop so much more
of the surface area. And all we're trying
to do is make it a lot easier to reason about
code, without having you to think about a
lot of surface area. The remaining surface
area is things that you can spend time thinking
about around your domain specific world. So
this is the API of react . Suppose to function
that gets the initial state of component,
render function that you can read from the
states. And a call back that sets state. You'll
notice that the set state is actually the
only API in to react. This is really the only
API you have to understande understand in
react. We also have this syntax sugar, basically
because braces are difficult to read. It looks
like templates, but it's not really templates,
there's no repeaters. In's no special directives,
there's no special conditionals, it's just
plain old JavaScript.
Now, reacts internals are pretty come collated.
The differing algorithm can be fairly complicated.
But the surface area that you have to face
as a developer to understand what's going
on in React is very simple, no new APIs just
a simple concept. You can build an incredibly
con next App but this, we did and up until
this point it sounds pretty good, right. But
nothing is free. So what are we giving up?
Implicitness. React favors explicit APIs,
and for you to write out your code as explicitly
as possible over built‑in Magic in many
cases we get request for implicit bubbling
of events because it's teed use to pass a
call back around or extra properties around,
well, turns out this is a terrible idea. It's
really difficult to follow code that depends
on implicit bubbling of vents, it means that
if either side disappears, you don't know
where it disappeared, let's say one call disappears
from your stack and later we realize that
actually lead to a bug that we didn't anticipate,
how do you find what? Do you have to go through
I have component and theirs of every component
and extraction along the way to find where
that happened? This is just one example. If
but it speaks to the idea that saving a little
bit of typing is actually not a good reason
enough for an abstraction.
It's much easier to recover from an explicit
API by adding some sugar than to undo an explicit
API. And we take new abstractions in Direct
very, very seriously, while you is to live
with a little bit of boilerplate (React) you
will probably understand and refactor your
code in the future much easier. We make mistakes
too, of course.
Um, if you're used to React you might have
noticed that's not actually how you write
React right now we built our own class extraction.
It was perhaps convenient. But in the next
version of React we're deprecate that and
going all in on the ES 6 class, it's not an
extended verse of ES 6 classes just ES 6 classes,
because it's not a one to one mapping it means
a little bit more boilerplate in some cases
but it means that since we're removing proprietary
feature from the library, you can use whatever
abstraction you want. Preferably we'll just
use standard JavaScripts so we don't add extra
weight to our industry. But, if you railly
do want to use a third party library, since
we provide the standard class system it means
that we can accept any kind of third party
class system as well. Because the standard
represents an intermediate representation
that can be shared across libraries, this
causes de‑couping as a side effect. Now
think about that for a minute, React already
has a small surface area, removing proprietary
features from the framework. Now, just because
you should mostly use standard language, it
doesn't mean you have to use all of it. So,
JavaScript already has a huge service area
if you want to keep adding more stuff to it,
then we have to remove something, because
otherwise it will just keep growing and our
industry will run out of head space. Or whatever.
But this is already being done through linters,
strict mode, VMs only optimize certain patterns.
So, the next thing I want to work on is basically
just formalizing this step of the process.
How do we remove features from existing language.
I mean they'll never be removed from the web,
because you can't remove things from the web,
but it can be removed from our industry's
mental service area.
So, let's put JS on a diet. Use poly fills
instead of libraries, write explicit and repetitive
code, only abstract to actually solve buttings,
not because it looks better. And rethink the
stack and purge. And start over again. Thank
you